everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over the Convery ation in the
Sicilian defense Sicilian offense starts
out with pawn to e4 pawn c5 and then
from here always gonna be Knight to f3
but black has so many different options
here the conversation starts out with
pawn to e6 after pawn to d4 which is
pretty standard for white here after the
exchange
Knight to a d4 then pawns gonna be
coming to a6 and this is the variation
that we're gonna be looking at today
there's a few main lines that white is
normally going to be playing Knight to
c3 is pretty common Bishop to d3 and
then lastly I see quite a bit of Queen
to d3 just centralizing the Queen very
strong move but we're gonna go over how
to effectively attack each of those and
then if you are playing against it as
white some variations to think about as
well so the first one we're gonna look
at is Knight to c3 this is the most
common at least the one that I see the
most now from here we really want to be
playing Knight to f6 but the problem is
the pawn coming here to e5 and there's
no way to really stop this and other
variations of the Sicilian defense this
is not an issue so if you think to
something like the knight Dorf extremely
common opening in the Sicilian offense
you have pawn to d6 and then after pawn
d4 we see the exchange and then Knight
to f6 very easy the pawn cannot come
here to e5 because the pawn is stopping
that that is the difference in this
variation because pawn to e6 instead of
pawn to d6 so there's small little
nuances make a world of difference in
the different variations and the
Sicilian defense so after Knight to c3
black would like to play Knight to f6
but then Pawnee 5 is gonna be bad Knight
to d5 and then after the exchange here
Queen to f3 is the key move here
attacking the pawn
this pond is going to fall so that's why
black wants to move to f6 but
unfortunately right away he cannot do
that so what black needs to be looking
to do is control this 'if I've squared
and there's two main moves that blacks
looking to do either Knight to c6 and
Queen to c7 both of these completely
finds how many over both of the
variations but for the most part they
are gonna play very similarly so we'll
start out with Knight to c6 here again
attacking this five square so that the
knight can freely come here to f6 now if
I try something like Bishop to f4
putting pressure on this a five square
black can actually still play Knight to
f6 because if pawn to e5 then Queen to
c7 this is fine because if the pawn
captures here then the Queen can come up
and capture here on f4 so if you see
another option let's say Bishop to e2
not worrying about defending the square
here on e5 so Bishop to e2 generated
castle on the King side go ahead and
play Queen to c7 getting both of these
pieces right here on c7 and c6 is gonna
be critical if you're gonna be playing
the conversation don't try anything
tricky just continue with the plan here
now if white wants to be extremely
aggressive they could play pawn to f4
this plays very similar to the King's
gambits pushing here castling on the
King side if they want to the other
option that they have is just a castle
on the King side so two options there if
you don't want to start out with Knight
to c6 you can also start with Queen to
c7 this is completely fine now if you
see Bishop to e2 continue the same thing
Knight to c6 one thing you could see is
maybe Queen to f3 here and if you see
this continue with Knight to sea
now you're not gonna see the Queen come
out here if the knight comes to c6 first
because knight c6 Queen here to f3 and
then the Knights gonna capture here on
d4 you can see that is a huge mistake
here but you absolutely could see it if
Queen to c7 then the Queen could come
down here to f3 that's the case Knight
to c6 as we discussed now if they do
want to exchange fine go ahead and
exchange right here always capture with
your be pawn it is possible to capture
here with your your D pond but I really
like to control the center of the board
you see black has a very strong pawn
structure you can always push forward
has two central pawns this is gonna be
extremely good and then later the rook
can easily come here to b8 just have a
very very strong a game from black and
really not committing too much and then
later if you want to play Knight to f6
you have that option as well now instead
of coming to c3 another variation that
you will see is Bishop to d3 just
centralizing the Bishop defending this
pawn here and getting ready to castle on
the King side now if you are gonna be
playing as black here I recommend Knight
to f6 the reason for that is a few of
them one you always want to be coming
Knight to f6 that's why you're playing
Queen to c7 that's why you're playing
Knight to c6 it's all to setup Knight to
f6 get your dark script if you've been
involved later on castle on the Kings
side that's the name of the game you're
not gonna be castling on the Queen side
with an exposed King here on c8 that's
not the game plan but after Knight to f6
this also sets a trap because you'll see
this all the time as soon as you play
Knight to f6 they feel like ah I'm gonna
go ahead and play pawn to e5 and force
this pawn to move but very different
where the knight is no longer here on c3
and why is that important because the
Queen can come to a5 check and then this
pawn is going to fall so Knight to c3 is
a pretty common move and then Queen City
5 taking the pawn and check so not only
is it
the best variation in my opinion but it
also sets a nice trap that a lot of
people are going to fall into so if
you're playing as whites you may see
some other variations so I will go over
those but if you are playing as black
playing at the con variation Knight to
f6 is going to be your go-to but some of
the other versions you may see if you
are white you could see 90 c6
just continue the theme say this is how
we're going to go if you're applying
white so you have a couple options you
could go ahead and take with your knight
right here they could capture castle on
the King side they could play rook here
to b8 if there's not a capture here then
really are going to be looking to bring
the knight back here to f3 and then
let's say they played Knight to f6 which
is what black is looking to do here
Knight to c3 Queen to c7 same game plan
as before Bishop to g5 one thing that
you will start to see more of in this
variation is the knight coming here to
g4 because there's no pressure really
being put on by any pawns here if
there's pawn h3 then the knight can come
to e5 and you can see it has protection
both from the night and of the Queen
here on c7 gonna be very difficult to
push this away there's no deep on to
push it in the pawn here on f2 is not
going to be moving anytime soon so those
are a couple options that you will see
if they move their knight back to f3 and
then if we come back and say instead of
Knight to c6 at the very beginning
another variation that you could see is
the bishop coming here to c5 attacking
the knight right here tonight it's
pretty much going to be coming to b3
every time attacking the bishop I don't
think it makes a lot of sense to bring
the knight back here to f3 just bring it
back to b3 attacking the bishop the
bishop should be coming back here to a7
if they want to retreat to e7 play
Knight to f6 in the future castle on the
Kings side they can I just feel like
Bishop to a7 is much stronger keeps it
on this long dark square diagonal
attacking
the f2 square which is a huge weakness
early on because the king is the only
piece that is defending this so this
puts a a lot of pressure on their
opponents after Bishop to a7 Knight to
c3 common development move Knight to c6
castle on the King side Knight to f6 all
of these are pretty standard as you can
see in each of the variations in the con
variation the last variation that we
will look at instead of fish coming here
to d3 sometimes you'll see Queen to d3
in this case I always recommend just
playing Queen to c7 now Knight to c6 is
eventually going to come there but
Knight to c7 is my go-to move here
Knight to c3 is going to be the most
common move that you will see and then
from here Knight to f6 if they want to
play something around a Bishop to e2 you
can see here both the Queen or the Queen
is defending the square here on e5 so
maybe Bishop to e2 and then Knight to c6
if they want to try something odd I have
seen people commentate on games where
Queen to g3 that's a lot of Queen
movements for me as white not a huge fan
of this but if you do run into this
Queen takes here after the pawn takes
here on g3 then the move blacks gonna be
looking for where is pawn to e5 there's
not a lot of times that black is able to
push forward and it makes sense but in
this case it absolutely does attacking
the Knights then it's gonna come back
here to e 2 and then Knight to c6 and
this is a very solid structure for black
does have a backward pawn here on d7 so
eventually we want to get the dark
square Bishop involved into the game
push up this pond get the light square
Bishop involved castle on the King side
has a pretty good structure
knowing that White has double pawns here
maybe looking to castle on the Queen
side but all in all this is a pretty
safe variation in the Sicilian offense
has a lot of strong attacking lines and
as many players playing the Sicilian
there
looking for an advantage playing his
black andis this is very aggressive if
you're looking for something and you
don't want to go with the common
neide Orff's and some of the others that
you typically see in the Sicilian
offense so thank you so much for
watching the con variation the cilium
fence if there's other variations you'd
like me to do feel free to reach out and
email me otherwise thanks for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video